[Music]
from calorie count to portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between halal guys in the uk
and the us this is food wars
[Music]
in the uk you can get your order in
three portion sizes as a small platter
as a regular platter or as a sandwich
the halal guys in the us your order can
come in three sizes
small regular sandwich we're gonna weigh
a regular platter in both countries to
see whose is the biggest
it's been so many episodes why don't we
just get bigger scales
bear with us one second
[Music]
first half is about 337 grams
337 plus three two one
six five hey
quick maths this thing we need to wash
this thing
it's getting funky in here here we go
the regular oh fits in perfectly
640 640 grams it's a full meal
oh man this smells so good fries in the
uk only come in one portion size
this one in the u.s the halal guys also
only have
one size fries look at this case seen
this
do you think it's keeping them crispy
don't get soggy very smart
very innovative i want to eat this so
badly we're going to weigh it first
this could be another brick
hey so aside of fries from uk halal guys
came to 213 grams
wait oh yeah okay yeah
145 grams for one
size of halal guys fries
oh yeah yo i've never gotten the fries
these are good
and crispy don't sleep in the halal guys
fries
in the uk a side of hummus only comes in
one size and it's this one right here
in the us of a hall guys hummus only
comes in one
size and of course we are going to weigh
it
so our side order from this came in at
246 grams
i'm gonna eat all of this as soon as the
camera stopped rolling
a side order of baba ghanoush in the uk
only comes in one size as well
in the u.s the baba ganoush at the halal
guys is also
just one size in the uk you can get a
side of falafel and it comes as a
two-piece serving
we did ask for some but i think the guy
forgot so we don't have any to show you
in the u.s the halal guys you can get
your falafel in three
sizes two pieces four pieces or six
pieces
we can also get falafel sandwiches let's
take some measurements
half a huffle sandwich is eight inches
in diameter and for the moment you've
all been waiting for we're going to
measure the gaff
with the tape measure but it's really
not fit to tusk
actually that's that's kind of worked
and our falafel sandwich has a girth of
let's say seven and a bit
inches from peta
to peta eight inches yeah
oh look at that and it's eight inches
thick eight and eight i like when things
are just precise like that
and finally it weighs 286 grams
and a falafel sandwich at the us halal
guys weighs
like exactly excuse me exactly
250 grams in the uk if you want dessert
hello guys you can get baklava
it comes in a two-piece serving of all
guys in the u.s the baklava comes in one
size
and this one piece this piece right here
oops i ordered two i guess i'll just
have to eat one oh my kid i'm eating
both of these
unfortunately hilar guys doesn't make
its nutritional information available
for its uk products we did find some in
the store
and luckily i took a picture from this
we now know that the sandwiches range
anywhere from 419 calories to 694
calories
and the platters range anywhere from 471
calories to 1049 calories
it's fairly safe to assume that the 1049
calorie platter is probably one of the
meat ones
with all of the sides all the sauces
pretty much everything you can get 1049
calories will take you to just over half
of your normal daily allowance
the combo platter is said to be halal
guy's most popular menu item this is a
regular combo platter before any white
or red sauce has been added
i would recommend not eating it until it
is added that's just me
our regular combo platter is 794
calories
23 grams of fat 10 grams of saturated
fat 1998
milligrams of sodium which i believe is
86 percent of your daily intake
and also 96 grams of carbs of course
we're adding white and red sauces right
okay the white sauce pouch one of these
is roughly 330 calories
37 grams of fat six grams of saturated
fat 420 milligrams of sodium
for 20 and two grams of carbs
see this guy right here each package of
their hot sauce adds only seven calories
but
89 milligrams of sodium let's talk about
the red source
now according to the halal guys website
their red source ranges from between 100
000
to 130 000 on the scoville scale to put
that in perspective sriracha is
somewhere around 2
500 on the same scale and the infamous
hot ones de bomb sauce
is around 135 000 so pretty close to
this
hello guys has something called the hot
sauce challenge what it is
is a small platter with 20 lines of
their hot sauce
and you got to be able to eat the whole
thing in 10 minutes
with no assistance of any beverages not
only during while you're eating it but
also five minutes after
sorry what are we doing so
one two
it's times like this where you're like i
should have a will written just in case
that's for oh my god if i don't make it
out of this
uh someone tell my cat that i love him
20. i'll just put this whole thing in
here
this is such a bad idea right yeah
all right
[Music]
oh my god this stuff is really hot
oh man i'm like getting like a metallic
taste in my mouth like
my mouth might be bleeding
hmm okay yep
that's immediately dispatching no slow
button here
oh god this was a mistake
aha that's like really good dude
oh god
how long's it been one minute down
horrible eyes are watering
the throat is hurting hmm
this is really hot my tongue back in the
mouth everything
no way i'm lost in five minutes i'm
breaking early oh god
i'm throwing the towel i can't do it
yeah holy sh
how long was that three minutes and ten
seconds
see now knows that is spice if you
emphasize something is spicy
at least deliver and that's what a lot
of guys have done
people who build up tolerance in their
mouth for spice
there's also the talents for going out
because
the worst thing about spicy food for me
is the second worst is eating it
the first worst is gonna be about five
hours
speaking of which
[Applause]
it would have been smarter to do this
the end of the shoot
now if you were to go with the falafel
sandwich in the u.s
it would be 641 calories 26 grams of fat
4 grams of saturated fat 1259 milligrams
of sodium
and 82 grams of carbs
[Music]
currently hello guys don't provide that
much information when it comes to the
ingredients of their meats and rices
what we do know as you can imagine is
that halal guy's food is indeed halal
certified
the halal guys chicken recipe is a
secret so we assume
similar to other middle eastern street
meats it is marinated
in herbs lemon olive oil salt and pepper
i got all this info from the halal guys
legendary eat story we did about a year
ago so uh thank you to those producers
for doing my homework
the beef is also a secret recipe but
from what we know it's likely to be
flavored with things like salt
pepper oregano and paprika but the halal
guys can't be tight-lipped on their
sauces now that they're available for
retail
so the hot sauce in the u.s and assuming
the uk ingredients
are ground red pepper vinegar salt
various spices question mark question
more question mark
and concentrated lemon juice uh white
sauce
soybean oil water egg yolk distilled
vinegar
less than two percent of salt sugar
spices
natural flavors xanthan gum sodium
benzonates and calcium
disodium edta or edta
to maintain freshness contains
eggs according to the white source
packets it contains soy bean oil
water egg spirit vinegar salt sugar
pepper preservative potassium sorbate
thickener xanthan gum
mustard antioxidant calcium disodium
edta
and natural flavoring for the halal guys
pita bread i had to do some deep
investigative journalism specifically i
called the halal guys in downtown la and
they told me that the pitas that they
use
are these cantos eurobread pre-oiled
is this the pita breads they use for all
halal guys
i called and emailed kantos and they did
not get back to me guys what's the story
so i'm gonna assume that they do so this
pita contains
unbleached unbrom bromated
nut unbleached unbromated enriched flour
niacin b complex vitamin thiamine b1
vitamin
reduced iron riboflavin b2 vitamin
folic acid water and soybean and
contains 2 percent or less of the
following ingredients
calcium proponeate a preservative corn
syrup solids
okay pumeric acid guar gum
salt sesame flour sodium bicarbonate
sorbic acid a preservative soy flour
sugar
vegetable manno and diglycerides
vegetable l-cysteine
wheat enzymes whole wheat flour and
yeast
one thing to look out for there is the
fumaric acid that they use while this is
practically non-toxic because the
amounts in our food are very small
the european union does say that in high
doses this can be nephrotoxic which is
toxic to your kidneys so you might want
to go easy on the pitters
one thing we found out just by
purchasing the product is that the
baklava in the uk actually contains some
questionable food colorings
the first is blue one also known as
brilliant blue
this is kind of hard to come by in the
uk as it's just fallen out of favor
thanks to the smarties controversy
blue one used to be the blue coloring
used in smarties in the uk however it
was removed after there was a panic
about it potentially causing
hyperactivity in children
it famously took smarties years to come
up with a natural replacement for the
blue coloring they finally settled on
spirulina which is made from seaweed
on a not unrelated note there's also
yellow five in here also known as
tetrazim
yellow five is one of the chemicals
highlighted by a 2007 study
investigating links between food
colorings and hyperactivity in children
the initial results did seem to show a
link between the two however since then
people have backtracked and said that
further study may be required
despite that foods containing these
chemicals in the european union must
still bear a warning that they may have
an adverse effect on attention in
children
we don't see a warning on this box so
hello guys you might want to update your
packaging
here is everything you will only find on
the menu at a uk hello guys
and here are the exclusives you can get
in the usa
yeah believe it or not this is probably
our shortest exclusive section ever all
the things you can only find on the menu
in the uk
are an orange fanta or a lemon planter
i'm assuming you guys do have fanta in
the us
but for me obviously fanta orange is the
classic however fancy lemon
absolutely amazing for some reason it's
not super common in the uk but if you go
into mainland europe particularly like
slightly hotter places like spain or
greece
this is kind of everywhere so for me it
just brings back memories of like being
on a beach bar with my family sipping a
fancy lemon
having a great time so forgive me if i'm
wrong i didn't see this anywhere on the
halal guys london menus
it is 16.9 fluid ounces
of the white sauce look how big this is
this is hilarious
ugh cider olives uh oh you can also get
a cider jalapenos
if the hot sauce wasn't hot enough here
you go
just get yourself a side of tahini for
desserts
you can also get a lot of guys cookies
that's pretty much it i'm gonna go and
lie down because hot sauce is a terrible
invention
cheers you know why this is trouble
though
because it still tastes really good i
mean
i'm glad for punishment